Atrus Alan I'm [ __ ] I think we're all
good thank you that is really sweet
y'all what's up guys yep I know yeah
yeah it's our birthday sorry
we both have Corona we both have Corona
we're celebrating thank you guys look at
that I'll be 37 I'll be 40 40 and you
just where the actual bra when I'm 40
Thank You Man thank you guys for coming
it's nice and they they wanted to prep
something else for you okay okay mind no
remix
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
thank you very much you the proud you
just got back from Hawaii you're welcome
tell your wives you know
[Music]
[Music]
deep in the gene she's warned me but the
butt you got makes me so lordy
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
these tough times it's our birthday yeah
what is the at Bank of Harmony Gizelle's
group does tour around you do gigs and
the competition : are those called
whitish you guys get a little but the
volume gets as the vocals get a little
bitter yeah yeah shaking my tofu
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]